foreign
Kansas City hi Tim welcome to the Ramsay
show
well hi you didn't want to talk about
being better than I deserve I get to
talk to you guys today I love it bless
your heart Merry Christmas to you how
can we help Merry Christmas to you so I
I have a question I want to know if a
decision that I want to make would be
considered in your guys's eyes Financial
infidelity and so my wife and I I've
been listening to you for a long time uh
you know my wife is not on 100 on board
we've we've come to like an agreement
between the Dave Ramsey Way and the not
Dave Ramsey way and that basically is
we've we've paid off all of our debt
right we have no debt except an RV and
we've had this RV for a couple years and
her the the agreement we came to was she
said I don't care if everything falls
apart and they come take this thing away
it doesn't matter it's a luxury and it
you know I say okay so I could agree to
that but
still beat down I'm like man I just want
to pay it off you know and and you know
we we have enough money and you know
enough margin uh that I I could you know
how much is the RV worth pay it off
uh probably about 20 000. what do you
owe on it
about
uh 17. you got the money in the bank to
pay it off
um
not not outside of our uh emergency fund
no okay I mean I I mean all of my money
is so where's the infidelity where is it
you're going to be lying to your wife
that's my question well we we the the
LIE would be we agreed like I agreed
that yes okay we we would work towards
paying off all of our debt but she she
said no I don't want to spend extra time
and money paying off the RV because she
did like she said what does she want to
do what what does she want to do with
the money so if you've got the margin
laying around in your budget what does
she want to do with that money
we moved on to
um the following baby steps you moved
under your own plan you're not following
the baby steps oh I agree I agree don't
then don't say okay yeah so I mean we we
funded our emergency fund and started
contributing to retirement okay now what
this means is you ever how old are you
41. okay when I was a little kid which
was like a thousand years ago it's
probably older than you probably way
older you probably don't remember this
we played this dumb game called mother
may I and if you took a step forward
without permission you had to take two
steps backward do you remember that
I do okay that's where you are you took
steps forward without permission now
you've got to take two steps back
meaning you guys got to get back to
ground zero and start talking again
about the vision for our life about
where we want to be when we're 70 years
old do I want to have a freaking RV
payment when I'm 90 right let's back up
to that instead of you agreed to some
stupid butt stuff you shouldn't have
agreed to and you guys need to back up
and work on your marriage and
communication and value combination and
then the RV becomes a symptom not the
problem
okay that makes sense
yeah yeah so the my my bottom line is
this you acquiesced and I'm not
suggesting you stir up trouble all the
time in your marriage but by acquiescing
you were under the illusion that you all
were now in agreement and you're still
not in agreement
it's lucky that you guys got that debt
paid off that that kind of happened by
by accident he did it yeah she she
agreed to that part of it he agreed to
that part of it so we accomplished the
one goal but you're not in agreement
about how money should be handled and
life should be lived that fooled them
into thinking that they were on the same
page but you guys are nowhere near it
yeah you're you're still not because
you're calling us saying I don't know I
don't want to do this
exactly made a bad deal
with my wife and I got to go back and
undo the deal because I didn't really
believe what I did and so that's why I'm
taking two steps back let's reset the
vision for our marriage and then the RV
thing is a non-8 it's a non-issue
because it's honestly Pretty stinking
silly but you've got this debt on this
RV it really is it's not just picking on
you or her but I mean do you want to be
92 with an RV dead no well the RV that's
not the problem uh it's the symptom